[Music]
let's go to jennifer in jacksonville how
to jaguar what's up jennifer
um hi how are you i'm good how are you
good thank you for taking my call of
course thanks for calling what's up
um so i'm calling about my husband um
in his life he's had a pretty
considerable amount of trauma and loss
that he's gone through
throughout the years
and that has caused a pretty big amount
of like anxiety and probably some
depression along with that
he is medicated for that from his
physician but
i also feel like he is using alcohol and
marijuana as like self-medication
so i'm just worried that you know he has
a family history of addiction
and i'm worried that it could spiral
down that rabbit hole
and i just really don't want that for us
and for our family
so my question is
how do i help him with this with this
particular issue when he doesn't seem to
feel i get the problem
can i tell you the truth
yeah you can't
and i hate that
right
and i know you know that and i know
that's
not what anybody wants to hear but you
can't
um he's gonna have to
come to
the
[Music]
conclusion that he's worth being well
and that he's worth being loved and that
he's worth healing and he's worth
connecting
and
weed helps things slow down and helps us
forget and alcohol things slow down and
forget and it's a cheap substitute
chemical for connection
and
as somebody who loves somebody who's
self-medicating that way
it feels like he's cheating on you with
those it feels like you're sitting right
here and saying why why
what what is it about me that can't fill
that gap and you need to hear me say it
has nothing to do with you
okay
at the end of the day you can't the only
thing you can do is decide
what will me and my kids tolerate
when it comes to our safety when it
comes to presence when it comes to what
are we communicating to our kids that
this is what marriage looks like this is
what a husband and a dad looks like
that's all you can control
tell me about some conversations you've
had with him
um so
i i mean i've encouraged him to to go to
counseling and
we went to marriage counseling together
but he has never done individual
counseling um i do think that he knows
that's necessary but it seems like
there's always an excuse
as to why it's not going to happen you
know he doesn't have time or he doesn't
want to spend the money or
something along those lines but he i
guess
when i say he doesn't think it's a
problem i think that he thinks um you
know because he's a functional adult he
has a really good job he has you know a
wife and a beautiful child and he's a
really good dad
i think that he just sees that and it's
like i don't see what the big deal is if
i want to do these things in the evening
gotcha
and what are you missing out on
like why is it a big deal he's got a
wife and a beautiful kid and a good job
like why don't you
once you back it off 30 jennifer
what are you missing
so
i guess he just like emotional
connection i feel like he just does
these things and then he's totally
disconnected we don't really
have like fruitful meaningful like
conversations in the evenings once we
put her to bed this is kind of what he
does and it's just
do this watch tv
and then on the weekends you know with
his guy buddies he wants to go rage and
have a good old time and just forget
about it and
i just think that emotionally in our
relationship that it really impacts like
our connection
i'm sorry that feels lonely didn't it
yes
how old's your little one
she's two and i'm actually pregnant for
a second one congratulations
thank you and um if you're just
listening to this i i my head drops um
it's so common for somebody for a baby
to be born and somebody with childhood
trauma
their body remembers that story
and their body sounds every alarm
possible and if you don't have the tools
on meaningful conversations you don't
have the tools
that help you lean into uncomfortable
relationships
then
mom and baby become this like just a
constant reminder of what a loser you
are and it just creates distance and
space and distance in space and so i'm
not going to beat him up the brave
hardest toughest strongest most raged up
thing he could do would be to go get
some
to lean into this discomfort
and most people most of the time lean
away
because it hurts it's hard it's scary
it's not an excuse it just isn't is
and
what i want you to do is get very very
specific
here's what that means
in 30 days i will no longer tolerate
marijuana in this house period we have a
two-year-old little girl
i will no longer tolerate alcohol in
this house
i need you here
on the weekends for dinner
or if you go out and get hammered and
whatever whatever whatever i need you to
know here's how this affects me
personally
you got to be very very clear and all of
these things are i statements not you
statements not you can't go do this and
you can
i'm saying in the house that i'm raising
a young daughter in that is ours by the
way
there will be no
uh we're not drinking on weeknights in
this home
period
we're gonna have to learn to talk um i
am not going to stay in a marriage where
we don't have communication
i'm not gonna stay in a marriage where
between the hours of 6 6pm until you
pass out i'm alone with a laptop in
netflix
it's that level of ownership of your
boundaries and then you have to have
what i think is the scariest thing for
somebody in your position it's an or
what statement
like or what
are you really going to leave them
or are you really going to hold this
boundary or are you going to cave and
you're going to say you know what
whatever
the picture of this thing this this
facade i'm just going to keep it going
until it crashes
right that or what statement is
terrifying right
yes you've thought about it tell me what
you've been thinking about it
i mean
i obviously don't
like divorce is never an option for me
and i just i've never pictured that for
my life and i've never pictured our kids
not being in the same house as both
parents
can i tell you where this usually leads
sure
it usually leads with somebody at work
being really nice to you
and you texting that person a little bit
more than you probably should
and then y'all right or
your husband senses the disconnection he
senses how frustrated you are at him and
how angry you are that he just keeps
smoking weed all the time
and he feels gross about who he has
become in his own marriage
that's where this thing usually implodes
and that's where somebody's got to flip
the lights on and say hey listen am i am
i on the right track
yeah
okay so
somebody's got to flip the lights on and
say hey we're on a bad trajectory here i
miss you
i miss you
and i don't have the tools to bridge
this gap you don't have the tools to
bridge this gap the only thing you can
do is go to counseling yourself have you
have you gone to individual
i have not okay i'd recommend that
okay because you're gonna need the
strength and the boundaries and the
practice and the all all the all the all
the right and you're gonna provide a
model for
this is how far i'm willing to go to get
well to connect with you
okay
instead of hey
you need to quit drinking so much at
home or i really don't like it when you
smoke weed
use i statements like
i miss you
i would like to connect in the evenings
without alcohol and without weed i don't
like sleeping with you when you've been
drinking the whole thing's just weird
i don't like
having to come in and put a blanket on
you i want you to come sleep in bed with
us like right you see what i'm saying i
want these to be ownership statements
and i statements
is your husband hurting
or is he just kind of a
is he broad out trying to live out his
brows
i mean i think he definitely hurts um
you know he didn't grow up with a father
figure his dad passed away and these two
his mom was during middle school and
high school was a drug addict
and then he lost his best friend his
brother passed away of a heart condition
um so i think he's just
he's definitely dealt with a lot of that
and his little two yeah having a
two-year-old in the house is sounding
every alarm he's got
because his body remembers the story
this is when dad dies this is when mom
gets off the rails and she is hurting so
bad and gets stuck in a cycle
um
yeah
can i just tell you i'm sorry
being lonely is the worst
and watching somebody you love love love
slowly go off the
slide
at the park is scary and i'm sorry
thank you please know that um
it's not personal
you know what i mean he's trying to stay
alive he's not not loving you he's
trying to stay alive and until he
chooses that
he's worth being connected it's going to
be a hard season
please please please make a phone call
talk to somebody today okay hang on the
line i'm going to send you a copy of on
your pass change your future
i want you to read it maybe you know
what i'm saying you too ask him if you
all read it together
look at that look at that they're gonna
read it together
um
and y'all read it together and
it also we'll send you a copy of the
audiobook if if one of you all doesn't
read and that we all can do it together
and you can have something to talk about
and maybe it will give you all a
connecting point that is different than
hey i need this and you need to do this
will give you a third a third party
right a third entity that y'all can
point at and say well the book said this
what do you think about that and it
makes that conversation a little bit
easier so i'm gonna send you two of them
hang on the line kelly will get your
info we'll get it shipped out to you